now i
am in a fake fight with snooki that is
not a real fight andy cohen is shutting
down rumors he's in a feud with jersey
shore star snooki
what is this snooki okay so it has been
i feel like people keep trying to poke
her and prodd her
into something and then it gets in the
thing that she and i are in some fight
he addresses it all during a recent
episode of watch what happens lives
after party with guests bone yang and
matt rogers but here's the moment when
andy asks the show's bartender joey
comasta who happens to be snooki's bff
to pass along the message you are
besties with snooki that's right will
you please tell her yes that i love
snooki yeah it's all love for andy so
how did this fake feud start well over
the years fans have wondered and hoped
snooki would join the real housewives of
new jersey given that she's from the
garden state and knows a few of the
housewives but andy an executive
producer of the reality show has shot
down the idea many times now recent
headlines are claiming there's tension
between the two celebs but andy's
clearing it all up while also explaining
why he doesn't think she's a good fit
the issue is that i've been asked is
should you know would we ever put snooki
on the real housewives new jersey
doesn't want to my only thing is
that she is so identifiable with jersey
shore and mtv she she built mtv
reality show
so
in my mind
i just thought it's like putting um
a kardashian on like another show that
has nothing to do with it it's like two
different worlds i agree that was my
only thing it was nothing personal and
bone yang's got andy's back this man is
a programming and casting genius
i mean you know what's right thank you i
just feel like it's a different universe
so there you have it no bad blood there
and snooki it seems she's squashing all
speculation of any beef between she and
andy snooki shared the watch what
happens live clip on twitter with an
epic reaction and as for if andy's game
to have snooki appear back on wwhl i
would love it i love hey i always love
her she's one of our great guests yes
now snooki's long been asked to appear
on the housewives franchise just last
year during the reunion episode melissa
gorga said she's ready to welcome her
with open arms i've text you about this
before yeah but you always give me a
heart i think i'd love that
i think she has kids now she's maturing
it's time for her to come to the ladies
the women but as the new jersey native
confirmed to et before she's not so into
the idea you know i have other other
things going on i feel like you know if
i'm a little bit older i would consider
it but i'm still young
this is fit monster time yeah
i'm not ready for housewives yeah seems
snooky's still booked and busy she's
currently focused on her return to the
jersey shore for the family vacation
spin-off did you miss me i'm kind of
freaking out right now
she reunited with her jersey shore fam
for season five after a two-year hiatus
and she told et why now was the time to
make the big return i think it's time to
come back because i miss my roomies and
definitely having fomo and you know just
watching them on tv and i'm not with
them it was just like a horrible feeling
it was like i missed them so much so it
was time
[Music]